quelques mots pour remettre en mémoire
Lorine cidérurgie récession reconversion
c'est dans ce cadre que s'intègre
aujourd'hui l'ouverture au public à
agondange autrefois célèbre pour ses
laminoires d'un stroupfland d'un Big
Bang stroumpf version petits hommes
bleus des parcs de loisirs qui poussent
actuellement un peu partout en France
l'un des enjeux de l'opération c'est de
créer de l'emploi dans une région
sinistrée reportage à agondange
mariemano
ces deux cheminées d'usine derrière les
schtroups sont les seuls vestiges de la
cidirurgie sur le parc qui ouvre ce
matin le Big Bang c'était il y a 4 ans
les laminoires quittai la scène pour
laisser la place aux petits ZES bleus
c'est eux désormais qui font travailler
les enfants de Cid
dururgistes j'ai fait partie de la
génération des enfants qui ont défilé
dans les rues de loui il y a quelques
années pour que le pour que leurs père
puissent garder leur travail quand quand
il était licenciement alors j'ai fais
partie des manifestations à longi où on
criait vivre et travailler en
Lorine si les jeunes travaillent ici
leurs pèr eux n'ont pas trouvé leur
place les cirurgistes on en trouve 50
sur les 800 emplois actuels du parc
parmi eux Pascal fin il vient de la
Solac pour lui c'est sauf qui
peut je pense qu'il faut il faut pas
avoir une mentalité de sidérurgiste mais
une mentalité bien ouverte à tout ce qui
peut vous c'est un savoir-faire
complètement différent mais aussi un
savoir-être parce que c'est peut-être
pas évident non plus qu'un cidérurgiste
puisse être transformé en hô ou en
hôesse
d'accueil les syndicats ne font pas la
fine bouche quand une région perd 20000
emplois en 4 ans on prend les
reconversions qui se présentent même
s'il ne s'agit pas du bon vieil emploi
classique d'autrefois quel type de
contrat avez-vous là euh C2i
c'est-à-dire
contrat mince
intermittent exactement contrat à durée
indéterminée intermittent une nouvelle
race de contrat qui permet de travailler
7 mois par an et de retrouver son emploi
après la fermeture du parc à hiver sur
les 800 emplois actuels il n'y a qu'une
centaine de contrats
classiques je ne crois pas que ce sont
du tout des emplois dévalués ou de
qualité en quelque sorte inférieur sonat
des emplois qui préparent tout à fait à
la vie moderne activité nouvelle emploi
nouveau c'est la philosophie que les
laurins ont fini par accepter avec
l'arrivée des schtrou encore